okay okay okay let's do this um as an
intro as an intro to introduce you sing
your name is sing a song but you replace
the lyrics with your name and then you
have to keep singing until someone gets
it
how about that I can thank you target I
can think of a song I got one ready I go
okay go cuz I was ready to go first
all right here I got you I am cinnamon
toast kin oh yeah I know cinnamon toast
Haledon whatever the [ __ ] how Allah
didn't yeah yeah I am thankful I'm sorry
I interrupted you is so nice all right I
guess I can do I could do next one do it
but the period Papa prepared a pie a
program puta [ __ ] dude
who the [ __ ] was that okay alright what
was that who are you yeah you haven't
had my chest voice I feel I smell pill
pill Peppa Peppa Peppa Peppa pair P P
PewDiePie
I'm 35 30 PI yo you can read my appeared
cuz all you say the [ __ ] song okay
thanks okay ready for my mines could be
soulful but okay in the little word in a
little would I go I have no idea
sometimes it lasts left look at your
staff your extender okay I got it
why what song called if that Adele oh
yes yes yes
oh what a dumb idea
alright max your time what I got know
your songs on Amy I'm elephant don't
worry that was that was splendid
mmm-hmm seriously I have no idea I named
it [ __ ] now a song you don't know
what song what's that what's that One
Direction song
car you just get to the point is that we
don't know just go [ __ ] thanks go [ __ ]
man
Anna dad dynamaxx Bofill max max max max
mofo next mo my folks
Michael next I think that's the real
lyrics actually hey already I think so
thanks thanks for sick in my username
nah I'm still I'm still waiting for it
max you like by yeah um moving the song
a little mermaid oh I want you to be
Undead
yeah I'll [ __ ] you wrecked it oh man a
max max for max Beaufort yeah I don't
know no we can't reach none of that is
that the whole mermaid absolutely
absolute what a mess your East End at
the time fix it the tunnel right here
and say hey ah crazy oh here we go
oh yeah we're drawing stuff I forgot
about that so you're the first one are
you gonna start the trend that we had
last time
no we're not we're not that childish you
know I'm just gonna be John penis
straight away there is this look like a
giant giant penis Emax it's ice cream
ever
Thank You chef oh yeah I guess where's
Marty like walkie talked to retos why is
this like an elf wearing a blanket
that's a lot
come on we just Weezy this is super easy
if you can't do this I don't even know
how we play uh right what are you it's
not Santa
okay a Santa mage Oh poppy come on come
on see okay you say commodities obvious
supply oh you got it can't got it hell
yeah count that come on if Ken's got it
then you gotta just say yes Oh y'all got
it good just on time uh yeah I know how
so was it without thinking project how
is that not a wizard
shooting magic he is just a wizard for a
long time that Valley
what's got it for the fame your name
Marlon lay three what ah I sign in with
Facebook
uh yeah we yeah yes house would credits
erotic but what dude like broke it and
there's a man holding it quick-draw the
man holding the stick there I nail that
bed like holding it that's fine
girl all right Ken show us your skills
every guy I've heard Ken's quite the
Picasso so I'm ready for this I am here
yo huh oh that's uh Spacek okay I guess
I'm like oh my god hahaha holy [ __ ] and
we all might paddy astray how did you
get why or what
oh I eyes I don't question you I didn't
get it kid he was like sunny-side up
eggs
no oops I don't think you do that how
did the pores dry ever what I like it
better try to put this on me I bet
everyone who's watching this or like
what the [ __ ] is that those are nipples
you two are the only ones so look this
is my max for sure oh it is max okay
umbrella I'm not alright that's oh yeah
oh yeah I got I got it first
god damn I gotta fight uh huh huh all
right bring it on kids all right I'll do
random on this one I feel adventurous
but look at what he's drawing like blue
the drawing you're actually gonna leave
all ten Dorian
cheetah cheetah cheetah shut up don't
give him the jack is that me maybe I'm a
man
oh yeah see this is going oh i smacks
his head so big don't worry about it
relevant at all actually I have it oh my
god oh you got it you got max fighting
to get it cuz then the face is very
touched
I love slaves was eating spaghetti Max's
never kissed anyone he doesn't
it's gone that's up what's up use kiss
is just like wait of course
wow it's not everyone does it I don't
get it what's going on uh the [ __ ] uh
already know how to there yet Oh Shia
all right uh fit no I got it
your clothes for shout yell oh uh why is
all sleeping on fire just lots of care
no but the succulence what I might have
dry those with redrawing it why do I say
kid where the [ __ ] is drawing it's me
it's morning
forgive me some hair there we go dude
that helping anyone stop you and it's
writing up with that but it's that okay
how do I wait you just got out of this
thing mm great table
Sam reduce oh ah everyone watching this
is rolling their eyes like what a bunch
of idiot God that how do you yarn that
loud like you on I don't know
I do I like a beer when I wake up Oh
yawn I thought you wanted was more like
haha sigh I mix those two uh never mind
oh yeah live like that like that
I couldn't be toys oh I was yeah okay
like everything was my very good so I
just have a penis on his head that's it
yeah hey that's a new fashion trend he
was a hard one this one I don't know
night ball they had fashion trends I
told him if I want you guys like yep
you're not gonna be able to get this oh
that's wonderful
I want it what the [ __ ] is this go where
the [ __ ] is this going
look how many letters that is I'm never
gonna get this oh oh I was close
ah zombie apocalypse so he's either been
to build-a-bear and he's giving him a
present or it's just taken some organs
out ah no that was not correct
he's giving him it's rising Lanka is
replacing something max don't you
I'm clicking cheater bottom yeah press
it is wow that was a thing yay
does that kick him out uh-oh a margin
the artist you're the Picasso
I'm second outside yeah go go again one
that did it I was game changer if you
did a good job
probably seriously please
how's that heart transplant who does a
heart transplant with a sword
sorry it's a medieval heart transplant
that's what it is how the Vikings do it
should know this yeah you're right I
should do this I knew that my
great-great grandfather taught me how I
was born I know how that makes sense but
yeah what's robot here he's like the
king Sweden forgave me best friends
Viking uh uh yeah but I'm the queen of
Sweden sign oh oh oh
sash for sure okay okay ask her what
Cavanaugh you beets give us so much oh
yeah don't worry what did you say honey
what did you think I said we're counting
on you and after that I didn't say
anything I said I'm fake I I said we
should make a rule but then I I backed
down
where's that I thought it was actually
ignore ignore all this
that's a long over this ignore this okay
I mean you can watch it if you want Ben
- but do you think we should tell him
about the eraser get your race things
what yes don't have time what is that
just you spent like 50 percent of the
clock rubbing at the [ __ ]
oh this is this is intimate I think I
saw a lady like her in total recall
except it was on the front nothing
yeah because I was thinking yeah I
couldn't tell which way she was facing
I'm sorry come on huh Crockett he's
dropping like a big Martin got it Java I
literally was it you going off the joy
guys just sat there looking at the words
okay cut down I thought mom was pretty
accurate yeah oh pretty chocolate a
sweetener at least I don't know river
water ocean okay the spill that's long
oh uh oh I know this I don't there we go
look at this I couldn't be more
descriptive I tried look at that
uh I got it night in [ __ ] what is that a
boat whose standard rental boat it's a
ratchet I guess Jack and Rose red those
are oh I knew that
close close thank you I tried think you
can all right Ken well you got okay good
is it banana nope you using the gray
Marcus that's not gonna work
oh no we can what's he doing the
experiments with colors you're
stretching yourself acting and he'd
really like that you playing piano on
his back I think that the end because
cross armies legs to fall is that why
does he have three things down there I
don't really get what's going on that
you went you went out of your way to
like draw that one like not what is that
do a scenario hey guys yeah he's not
look much like ken ken try again try
something different this is no Aiki okay
that what those ladies what it was what
she said the first time you actually
said the answer to begin with uh
match Oh - time
what's that what's always a close-up of
his hand it's like a call I can't
scratch this go for it good job Ken good
job i like meme's guy i got points you
mad you choose multiple layers today I
got thanks - shut up it ladies just
about say points you couldn't say that a
second ago
is it here [ __ ] uh I got this [ __ ] oh
yeah giving out free points I get it
what has white for breakfast what what
uh always fell in right spelling wrong I
had to - I'm an idiot
oh [ __ ] uh them English classes didn't
do me good well I'm not American so you
don't have an excuse whatever
I'll stop the [ __ ] this is not that
difficult husband order the yellow
markers out is banana it's got a big
bucket it's a taco
all right she was she damn somebody
pressed it cheaper when its back to
Saint Valentin Vernon I please
damn you Mack Oh God okay I was aware
that there is an eraser so don't think
this is why I'm dead what watch what do
you have a razor at the star you're
making fun of me Martin this is die die
I love you okay okay that is very
romantic
it is I don't like it here some boil
singing I know are you two are getting
exactly the same thing would you guess
jelly you snore watching till we kiss I
think this is a banana nighttime uh what
there we go huh oh I got it I got it I
got it
yes doesn't have it and I have Oh Jade
space that's no long time it does
on a second I didn't need a car to get
swatch you should have meant made it
yellow what a bat signal inside my man
oh that would have been awesome
where's the boon it we're just worried
you guys were shy oh thanks oh oh not
not a baby
oh wait hahaha Oh idiot where's the
racer oh my god what are you what the
hell else gonna be baked Oh think of
what this is but then turn it to a fruit
I thought it was a friend what that was
like bomb malice I could let you do sell
the bomb
then what the [ __ ] are you doing
well I know you Skinner got it yeah Liam
can be more handsome can't stuck well
enjoy your summer jobs up Meg come on oh
that's nice I gave you like this oh yes
for this it's like the citizen turn into
a fruit what else gonna be peach all
right this is gonna be I thought it was
an apple I thought it was an apple he's
a little bit abstract literally I'm
strong Oh
in ball to ball I want the [ __ ] max he
said it was gonna be abstract it does
get more abstract than that that's what
it is I got it right a point head nope
tip no crack Oh always bleeding that's
the out that way I got it don't worry I
have to go to one in five men it's all
right it's not no one has to feel
awkward here this is totally normal
hey pills for the hay ignore it okay
yeah this is a perfect
salad I'll load Oh what it is I don't
know what it is
yes yeah yeah just yeah yeah that's good
what that's great
I got it how the hell did I get it I
think I wrote come here
hmm ah to tell I lived and I earn income
last son okay
I think he's the winner undisputed oh
man well son whoo that means
Martin wins how about a round of
applause yeah I am I'll talk to myself
so glad for you oh did you thank you and
yes we can fail yet good up near and get
it back you good sport
all right so um this is fun
Scooby do an outro yeah why wait no no
no no don't don't even think you could
do get off that easy
I have no idea what to do that so if
anyone has an egg I'm cinnamon toast kid
I'm not about everything our songs all
sitov toes can beautify shut up shut up
yes [ __ ] painful Oh No
my mom my mom my mom is my mom get an
umbrella I want an umbrella under my
umbrella my umbrella
- Narnia and then why